élections municipales le débat bienvenue
dans ce débat des élections municipales
2020 consacré donc à la ville du carve
et j'ai l'honneur de l'animé avec alain
livory quatre candidats têtes de liste
sont présents dans notre studio nous
vous les présentons sans tarder
succinctement avant d'entrer donc dans
le vif du débat et alain vous commencez
par alors par ordre alphabétique nous
avons choisi de commencer donc par ordre
alphabétique par louis boutrin 61 avocat
président de martinique écologie membre
du conseil exécutif de la septième
depuis 2015
conseiller municipal d'opposition depuis
2014 et vous allez conduire la liste
alliance car des siennes ensuite il y à
thierry claveau 54 ans cadre de
collectivités directeur général des
services de la ville de basse pointe
il est à la tête de la liste agir pour
incarner audacieux et fort jean claude
et qu'en ville 67 ans ppm cadre edf à la
retraite
maire depuis 2008 du garbet et vous êtes
la tête de liste et de réussir de réunir
pour réussir le quart ben voilà est le
quatrième candidat présent pour ce débat
et louis-georges griffith âgé de 47 ans
cadre ministère de la justice membres du
rdm conseiller municipal d'opposition au
carbet depuis 2014 vous conduisait la
liste intitulée incarner solidaire et
ambitieux et maintenant avec voilà une
courte présentation de la commune du
jour alors le carbet en un clin d'oeil
le carbet est située sur la côte caraïbe
entre bellefontaine au sud et saint
pierre au nord
la paroisse a été écrit en 16 145 et le
carb est devenue commune le 2 juin 1837
la fête patronale a lieu le 25 juillet
le carbet compte aujourd'hui 3536
habitants des quartiers sienne écart by
siens c'est aussi l'une des communes
phare du nord caraïbes notamment sur le
plan balnéaire avec ses plages de sable
droit merci alain le tirage au sort a
désigné monsieur thierry claveau pour
donc répondre à notre première question
c'est moi qui la pause pierrick lavaud
le maire sortant jean claude et qu'en
ville est candidat à un troisième mandat
alors qui
avait indiqué auparavant qu'il n'en
ferait que deux est ce que cette
situation est de nature à vous
surprendre comment vous appréciez ce
changement finalement de positionnement
du maire sortant
écoutez tout d'abord avant de répondre à
votre question je voudrais rappeler que
si nous sommes candidats effectivement
c'est parce que nous nous rendons compte
qu'après douze années d'immobilisme de
l'équipe sortante
il y a lieu de réagir et de faire
quelque chose néanmoins le peuple
haïtien a quand même fait confiance à
lille sortante et notamment monsieur
qu'en ville pendant ces deux années là
hein c'est quand même important
pourquoi je dis ça parce que je pense
qu'il mérite quand même le respect il a
dit l'a reconnu en temps et en heure
qu'il a commis quelques erreurs il ya eu
quelques loupés c'est rare de voir les
lieux le dio j'ai l'impression de
peut-être le début de la saison le pas
du tout pas du tout je fais preuve
d'objectivité et de respect et
aujourd'hui monsieur et qu'en ville
et je dois vous soyez tout vous trouvez
normal qu'il veuille se présenter pour
un troisième mandat que cela puisque si
je reconnais que les douze années on
était douze années d'immobilisme
c'est bien parce que je ne peux pas
imaginer le faire rempiler pendant
encore six années un donc mais néanmoins
j'ai il force le respect c'est je tenais
à le dire parce que c'était pas autant
d'accord ça ne vous dérange pas outre
mesure qu'il ait annoncé auparavant
qu'il ne ferait que deux mandats et que
finalement il aura l'occasion de
répondre lui même lui a déjà d'ailleurs
posé la question mais ce que je veux
dire vous vous en tant que candidat
comment vous appréciez cette se changent
l'inde est visionnable en jeu
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir qu'est ce
que deviendra le carbet dans les six
années comme suit qu'en ville a dit à un
moment donné qu'il se présenterait plus
après deux mandats et qu'il se
représente
ça le regarde il va expliquer à la
population du ko mais qu'est ce qu'il en
est je n'ai pas à faire de commentaire
sur les choix dissout sa motivation
monsieur des feats c'est votre deuxième
présentation de candidature vous n'avez
pas peur d'être l'éternel challenger
beaucoup c'est votre
quand l'éternel challenger par titre
indique c'est une quatrième ceni
quatrième candidature non monsieur
griffith ouais bah lui
peut nous dire s'il va lille va nous
l'expliquait il va nous dire c'est une
deuxième présentation sur votre nom
alors c'est oui c'est une deuxième
présentation puisque en 2014 je me suis
présenté pour la première fois et nous
sommes sortis donc deuxième par le
nombre de voix au carbet ce qui fait que
depuis 2014 sur le polder pourquoi
pourquoi il dit que c'est la quatrième
fois monsieur boutrelle pourquoi vous
dites que c'est la quatrième fois mais
demandez lui
deuxième faute et bien sûr des deux
têtes de liste oui j'étais candidat oui
j'ai été conseiller municipal de ce la
liste d'alexandre mouriès à l'époque
puis sur france 2 d'abord en claudiquant
très bien et vous monsieur boutron vous
avez de multiples casquettes liées entre
autres à votre présence à votre élection
à la ctn et vous voulez être mère ça ne
suis pas un peu beaucoup savaient dans
un monde de déloyauté vous permettez
d'afficher publiquement ma loyauté
on verra le fait de marie jeanne qui m'a
confié un certain nombre de missions qui
sont des missions transversales aux taux
de politique publique notamment des
politiques de transition écologique
donc c'est une confiance et c'est une
histoire de confiance mutuelle chacun
gère ses missions comme diffa non je ne
lis trahit pas je lis cher je les essaie
de les accomplir
du mieux lors du bilan de la ctm offrir
le bilan de mes missions
actuellement nous sommes dans un combat
pour les élections municipales du carbet
et je devance la question
c'est ma troisième c'est ma troisième
candidature au carbet et vous savez bien
que les grands hommes politiques n'ont
pas tous eu le même destin électoral
puisque si on prend l'exemple de
mitterrand
battus en 74 il a été auparavant battu
en 65 avant une victoire en 81 et
victoire historique mais néanmoins
néanmoins louis boutrin vous prenez le
risque ou la chance je ne sais pas
comment vous
apprécié cela mais en tout cas si vous
êtes élue maire du carbet vous serez
contraint de démissionner de votre poste
de votre mandat de conseiller exécutif à
la ctm
donc c'est un choix clair que vous
faites là parce que dire que vous avez
de nombreuses passions que vous allez
accepter par effectivement loyauté
envers le président du conseil exécutif
alfred marie-jeanne mais voilà vous
serez peut-être contraint d'arrêter ce
que vous avez entamé à la ctm monsieur
caruge soyez rassuré le sujet de ma
thèse de doctorat public en droit public
site un sujet de droit constitutionnel
donc je le fais cette candidature en
toute connaissance des dispositions du
code électoral sur le cumul des
motoristes sur le cumul des mandats père
mythique je m'exprime oui je suis venu
pour cela qu'ils n'autorisent pas
l'exercice simultanée de demande à
l'exécutif
donc soyez rassurés je le ferai en toute
connaissance de cause du code des
dispositions du code électoral
alors monsieur le maire sortant qu'est
ce qui vous motive encore votre pour
quelques semaines encore expliqué ce qui
motive cette troisième parce que comme
le disait bertrand caruge vous aviez dit
pourtant que vous n'allez pas vous
représenter une troisième fois vous avez
d'abord permettez moi de dire bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir les concurrents
et du bonsoir aussi à la population car
les siennes il sait qu'à la martinique
il ya tout auditeur puisque je crois que
nous serons à l'écouté aussi de la plus
large
alors oui je ne représente effectivement
j'avais dit en fait comme je suis en
général un homme de parole
j'avais dit que je me présentais que
deux fois mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il ya une prospective
il ya une vision il y a un bilan
évidemment qu'on le veuille
le regard dit par le quart vide les
trois quarts aux problèmes que c'est le
bilan de jean claude et qu'en ville ou
le lindane une équipe de l'équipe de
l'équipe
eh bien cher s'il ya personne dans
l'équipe pour prendre la relève mais
pour le moment nous avons décidé avec
l'équipe que je continuais et qui
effectivement joué placé nous aurions vu
que pour que notre que notre une autre
est de pouvoir être maire de l'année cas
c'est d'abord une prospective je crois
que les obus dont il sera soumis à rude
épreuve par deux concurrents vous voulez
dire le quart vide sera est toujours vue
on ne voit pas le câble et d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dit monsieur livory
dit que le carb label commune du corbu
la commune attractive et au fait c'est
factuel n'est pas envers des environs
depuis 12 ans en plus c'est la cible est
très fort plus mais je lui avant radio
compris belle il a effectivement mais
c'est plutôt parce que je suis heureuse
jusqu'au bout et je suis je suis là bas
aussi
nous souhaitons pas que qu'il y ait soit
des égos démesurés soit des familles
comme ça qui à vienne qui prennent le
pouvoir nous souhaitions que aujourd'hui
nous ayons une corbeille avec une vision
cohérente avec avec une conception sont
que des l'avenir attendez que c'est ça
que les familles des familles quoi des
familles politiques laisse pas les
données de sa vie et sa vie des familles
des clans dès que nous avons nous avons
aujourd'hui appeler le 15 mais il y a
huit ans d'avoir découvert l'avion
tarbes et déchiré des chiffres
complètement déchirés ou les cous et les
peler les frères et soeurs se battait il
y a effectivement et aujourd'hui nous
avons appelé le corps dès aujourd'hui
les clandestins vous le diront
le carb est une belle ville avec le
sentiment humain d'être ici est donc
aujourd'hui nous continuons à pouvoir
donner à notre commune cette dimension
cette activité cette vision cette
cohérence dans un avenir
alors justement nous allons nous nous
sommes rendus au carbet ce matin
bertrand s'est rendu au carbet avec
patrice jean-guy tôt et nous avons
recueilli l'avis des carmes est sûre je
vous pose de les écouter c'est moi qu'on
parle déjà pas mal du quart des mails
encore j'aimerais bien que ça puisse
être plus développés c'est dans le
gourma rappelle très bien comment le bo
était bien animé c'est quand je dis le
beau c'est à dire en face
du côté de la mairie la place ici et
j'aimerais bien que ce soit plus animées
comme ça moi je suis marré pêcheurs du
grand bain donc un aménagement pour le
débarquement du poisson
bon nous sommes aidés par la
municipalité pour l'avenir bon c'est les
jeunes mais il faut que les jeunes sont
présents mais aussi par la paie acp ue
et toubon le quart bellegarde et ça
bouge vont nous avons des jeunes nous
avons de jeunes qui quand même qu'ils
sont à l'école à l'école maritime
d'autres unités donc bon il
la pêche avec nous bon il ya d'autres
jeunes c'est un développement pour le
carbet des mobiles intégrés ou même la
foulée imhoff
il avait commencé déjà médiathèque nous
avons fini généré 2 qui finissent à même
la cité - mon séjour je suis là quand
tout nettement la place à énormément de
choses qui évoluent en commune en
flammes après économique ape tous me
tout en instaurant dans 10 de plage de
médecins ignorent qui n'est ni hypothèse
dix neo fleurissent nyon machine legend
du mythe de garage c'est au bout du quai
conti communicants ban ki moon à 4000
habitants mettent à penser fonctionnant
pas halluciné fortune tout noté en se
massant wakim lanouf et déjà améliorer
l'existant alors ça fait déjà réagir sur
le thème nous allons commencer par
monsieur moutreuil qu'est ce qui vous
fait réagir juste une chose je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez
m'expliquer le sens du tirage au sort
nous avons vu tout à l'heure
il me semble que lors du tirage au sort
j'avais le numéro quatre et que c'est
monsieur le maire sortant qui a parlé
qui apparaît non non non non on a signé
le premier le deuxième ou troisième le
canon et non pas du nom là joseph bialot
symboliser le bien expliquer comment ça
se passait on ajuste désigner celui qui
débutait la première question et ensuite
celui qui terminait c'est monsieur oui
ne vous énervez pas mouche au niveau
ligue 1
gardez votre calme soyez si je pose une
question non non ce que je souhaiterais
et je le dis en toute sérénité
je ne souhaiterais pas que le débat
public et que le débat politique
sa part entre une partie de poker
menteur et que l'on puisse effectivement
tromper l'électeur en faisant des
pseudos micro trottoir avec avec des
colistiers du moeurs du maire sortant
ce n'est pas loyal je le dis comme je le
pense
donc maintenant alors nous aurons
canonisé en cause la façon dont j'ai
réalisé ce micro trottoir je les fais ce
matin au carbet g je suis allé à la
rencontre d'habitants et d'habitants du
carbet je n'ai pas demandé aux gens leur
identité qui
était ce qu'il faisait s'il faisait de
la politique ou pas je les ai laissé
moins terminer monsieur boutrin s'il
vous plaît je les ai rencontrés en tant
que personnes qui habitent le carbet je
leur ai demandé s'ils habitent le carbet
ça c'est leur responsabilité s'ils
disent qu'ils habitent le carbet et
qu'ils ne résident pas au carbet ça
c'est leur responsabilité joueurs posent
leurs questions
la question ils me disent qu'ils
habitent le carb et je leur demande
quelles sont leurs attentes par rapport
aux élections municipales qui arrive
voilà c'est tout je ne demande pas
l'identité des gens donc quand j'ai
interrogé les gens je ne connaissais pas
leur nom ni leurs positionnements
idéologiques ou sur telle ou telle liste
voici la réponse que je vous fait vous
pouvez poursuivre allez-y mais chez rien
d'autre à dire sur le micro trottoir et
ben voila merci alors monsieur greffe et
oui alors la rue oui malaisie il ya
plein de choses que tu ton été
oui il ya beaucoup de choses tout
d'abord je veux je veux revenir quand
même sur les propos du maire il ya
environ cinq minutes notamment et sur sa
représentation au carbet
quand donc le maire nous dit monsieur
jean claude et qu'en ville
il était prévu qu'il fasse du mandat et
il revient parce que son équipe lui a
demandé de continuer écoutez je mets pas
en cause son retour nous sommes dans un
pays démocratique il a tout à fait le
droit de se représenter
mais à la question que je pose est ce
que la population par rapport au bilan
du maire a autorisé le maire à revenir
première question deuxièmement monsieur
monsieur le maire nous parle de son
bilan et le maire sortant où il nous
parle de son bilan ce big souffle c'est
bien monsieur convient donc nous parle
nous sommes de son bilan est il
cependant ajouté un plus évident qu'il
se souffle des démos cependant si ce
second visage cependant ce bilan nous
l'avons ne l'avons jamais il ne l'a avis
ne l'a jamais fait et puis
ce qui me choque c'est quand on me dit
que le quart ben est une commune
attractive
quand même à l'étang ne rigolons pas
nous passons de 3736 habitants à 3535
oui vous perdez deux de ses six
attractive
on perd de l'est pas et au contraire il
faut faire il faut tout faire pour que
cette commune soit une commune
attractive et là nous sommes en train de
perdre des habitants et l'attractivité
c'est là qu'elle qu'à notre activité on
prendra des restaurants les restaurants
n'ont pas attendu la municipalité en
place vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure ça
fait plus de vingt ans qu'ils existent
ces restaurants plus de 20 ans et je
vous dis c'est un patrimoine
par contre je puis dire que depuis
l'arrivée alors de monsieur de monsieur
jean déjeux réaction non parce que dit
on va pouvoir développer aborder ces
sujets là donc on est au pire on voit le
jeu j va directement sur le micro
trottoir
donc il ya quelqu'un qui parle du
développement du bourg ben je permets
muté moi de vous dire que depuis 2008 il
y a un projet de boer qui a été réalisé
et depuis 2008 ne l'avons pas vue
ensuite j'ai entendu parler un péché
d'un pêcheur qui parle d'aménagement de
la plage ça fait 12 ans quand même que
rien n'a été fait pour les pêcheurs
alors que nous avons un projet
d'aménagement de la page
depuis la première mandature qui
englobait aussi les marais pêcheurs on
parle des jeunes rapidement je pense que
mon jeu a le temps de revenir sur tout
ça on va préciser ces points se sont
font partie gestes des thèmes que non
que ça nous aidera à aborder
alors monsieur claveau sur le sur le
micro trottoir on a parlé du
pour qui se meurt qu'il ya un manque de
vie centre du centre bourg et de et des
jeunes également écouter salissant du
centre bourg il est évident qu'il se
meurt et c'est pas depuis l'arrivée de
monsieur et qu'en ville sa date depuis
très longtemps je vous assure je ne suis
pas là pour défendre leur ville mais il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont
cette place qui était la place jules
grévy avait aménagé à l'époque bat ça
fait très longtemps sa date du père l'a
fait on est donc c'est une vieille
affaire s'il ya composants 12 ans il
aurait dû penser autrement cette place
effectivement parce que moi je propose
pour peut travailler de façon plus
méthodique un véritable schéma
d'aménagement directeur d'aménagement du
territoire qui puisse permettre de
penser l'atterrissement autrement c'est
à dire que moi je pense qu'il faut
prolonger le bo vers le théâtre de
verdure jusqu'à la place des caraïbes et
pour faire revivre ce bout du carbine
bon et je l' ai dit tout à l'heure je ne
suis pas je ne veux pas que des
floodeurs monsieur comme je devais dire
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que c'était de
12 années d'immobilisme
alors et est ce que est ce que en
effectivement monsieur et qu'en ville je
vais apporter des solutions non moi je
dis solutions concrètes
c'est le schéma directeur d'aménagement
du territoire qui sera amendée par la
population qui sera présentée par des
techniciens compétents et qui sera
amendée par les consultations là qu'on
va faire pour terminer monsieur qu'en
ville
votre avis sur ce micro trottoir et
notamment la question de la médiathèque
eux il ya un des intervenants y est sûre
il dit qu'ils auraient aimé voir la
médiathèque à 15 jours parce que ça fait
plus de deux ans que oui en fait pas
pour autant mais ça fait quelques années
que non je voudrais d'abord parler du
bourg le bourg effectivement monsieur
caveau merci de vos considérations du
cousin sur dix ne sont pas des
considérations partisanes
voilà donc le bo était effectivement
déshérités des invités je veux dire par
là qu'aujourd'hui nous refaisons des
manifestations le mot demandé aux
commerçants du bourg vous verrez qu
aujourd'hui la municipalité que j'ai
l'honneur de diriger et les élus qui
innove au carbet font des manifestations
culturelles et c'est important on
dépensait plus aux places non retour pas
du tout pas du tout il y a eliane vision
cohérente et à la côte
je crois que le quart peyton culture
c'était pourtant je crois qu'on ne sait
pas d'où l'importance de la médiathèque
mais c'est sûr messieurs jean régis
veille à new york mais il faut savoir
aussi qu au bourg il y as on a eu cali
on a eut pris 20 on a eu on a eu des
artistes
on a eu des auteurs on a eu toutes
sortes de pièces de personnes au bout ce
qui ne se faisait pas que l'avons fait
allais-je et ils vont la médiathèque la
tête chez le sujet fait que le vaste
sujet dans le ciel on parle de la fsu
mais bien sûr mais j'assume mais
j'assume oui oui ce n'est pas tenable
oui je vais la terminer avec les lois de
genève hug palais sous bouquet ominami
ex c'est la faute en mêlée est déjà fait
le financement d'une falaise le
financement était faible et simplement
la sfio je reviendrai je suis un sujet
là je reviens du reviendrai sur ce sujet
par les bretons voilà vos concurrents
sont déjà prêts là je verrai plus tard
g2 ils veulent en parler mais je dirais
que oui mais c'est toujours comme cela
écoutez en douze ans nous avons fait
certain nombre de choses mais vous
verrez non pas tout réussi nous sommes
désunis
nous sommes en médiathèque à écouter il
se met à parler s'il vous plaît à les
analyser un jour sinon jean-françois on
sent pas dans le dialogue
nous avons réussi beaucoup de choses
mais cette poule
d'accueil de sujets qui sont des sujets
énorme mais oui nous avons promis de
finir la médiathèque nous la finirons
cette année cette année effectivement
nous avons eu du retard beaucoup de
retard beaucoup et j'assume beaucoup de
retard cette médiathèque louis boutrin
vous avez beaucoup réagit sur la
médiathèque
oui quand j'écoute me suis qu'en ville
chez le proverbe
un proverbe qui me revient à l'esprit
c'est particulièrement vrai en politique
et le quart ben est un bel exemple
beaucoup savent parler mais bien peu
savent faire je suis quand il sait pas
faire monsieur qu'en ville ne s'est pas
monter des dossiers
monsieur quand vino sipa faire des plans
de financement
monsieur qu'en ville ne s'est pas
finaliser des projets et nous avons une
série de projets qui sont à l'arrêt dans
la commune le secteur mis ses projets
parmi ce projet bien sûr il ya le centre
sportif d'hébergement depuis 2010 je
vais les énumérer ce sera encore plus
simple
depuis 2010 il est en attente il a reçu
des subventions ou cela et il ne l'a pas
fait ensuite nous avons la médiathèque
et la médiathèque
il dit qu'ils veulent terminer la
médiathèque ce qui n'a pas plu ferrand
12 ans ne va pas le faire en dix huit
ans parce qu'il a reçu contrairement à
ce qu il dit il a reçu des financements
le coût de la médiatique 2 million cent
mille euros
il a déjà eu un million 19000 euros
attribuée en grande partie par la
septième quart pris le relais des deux
collectivités antérieures des monsieur
letchimy nous étions des gens en attente
de pièces justificatives pour mise en
m'adaptant du sol mais la médiathèque ne
peut pas se terminer
vous comprenez qu'il ya deux étages et
qu'elle n'est pas aux normes il ya même
pas un ascenseur privé au deuxième étage
alors que on sait des prescriptions en
matière d'urbanisme pour justement
accueillir les personnes à mobilité
réduite
la médiathèque il va falloir la faire
fonctionner avec qui elle même pas un
appel à candidature avec qui avec une
personne pour faire fonctionner ses
médiathèques
il faut au moins trois personnes or
juste un point
le concept même est dépassé le concept
de mediatek donc le projet et a du coup
mais le prochain alors qu'est ce que
l'on va faire et c'est non à l'alliance
krabi sienne qui allons terminer cette
médiathèque
parce que nous avons déjà un plan de
financement qui est bouclée et la
commune ne va mais aucun euro dans ce
coin de financement mesure mais on mais
je finis on met aux normes la
médiathèque
on donne une nouvelle orientation une
double orientation vous savez que 50 %
des français n'ont pas accès au
numérique
c'est ce qu'on appelle la fracture
numérique en outre mer c'est pas 50
c'est 75%
les personnes âgées qui veulent tout
était dit nationalisée
c'est une facture totale dans le nom
carayon nous allons pouvoir du meilleur
temps de nous à lui donner non est à son
deuxième orientation et nous sommes nos
phases parce qu'il faut que les autres
s'exprimer sinon vous mais si mauvaise
opération
un temps de parole à risque les smashing
c'est important ça l'orientation que
nous avons donné c'est une orientation
vers la biodiversité de marine il ya des
atouts sous la côte caraïbe et nous
allons faire un centre de recherche des
chercheurs vont pouvoir venir dans cette
médiathèque les jeunes également
et tous les lycées de la ville de la
côte car alors monsieur greffer sur
cette nouvelle et agir parce que c'est
quand même grave
nous avons 600 élèves depuis 2011
2010-2011 qui sont privés de culture qui
sont privés de cette médiathèque vous
rendez compte
un élève qui rentrent au collège ils
parlent ils passent le bac il quitte la
martinique la médiathèque n'est pas
terminée je sais que quelque chose c'est
que effectivement monsieur boutrelle a
dit le puits des opérations était de 2
millions cent mais en plus des aides de
la collectivité aux communes un million
et aux dix neuf mille huit cent trente
cinq mille euros
le maire a reçu aussi 712 milieu haut de
l'état dont il a touché un million sept
cent trente deux mille pour pouvoir
terminer cette médiathèque pourquoi elle
n'est pas terminée
c'est la question et puis ce son rapport
d'orientation
ce qui me choque c'est que depuis 2016
la ville devait investir exactement 736
1000e hausse et ce qui reste
depuis 2016 rien n'a été fait si ça n'a
pas été fait depuis 2016 vous pensez
qu'on noit une médiathèque en 2020 1020
2021 ou non c'est pas possible
donc il faut qu'on ait des explications
caisse où est passé cet argent qui a été
touchée par la ville la question vous
est posée jean-claude etc en ville il
vous reste un peu de vous êtes un peu en
retard vous avez un léger retard sur le
temps de parole dont que vous vouliez
nous avait utilisé l'argent pour autre
chose
c'est une question que je vous pouvez
bien sûr mais sur des noms mais l'enjeu
des bêtises l'argent a été utilisé pour
la médiathèque
je suis et effectivement nous avons
repris vu les difficultés ici c'est nous
avons aussi les compétences nous avons
demandé et nous avons signé le contrat
avec la sp et le martinique qui est
dirigé par madame montrose pour pouvoir
reprendre au point la maîtrise d'oeuvre
et vous qu'on voit effectivement
terminée cette diatribe et c'est
pourquoi avec eux nous vous disions avec
conviction que cette médiatique serait
terminée en 2020 je crois aussi qu'il
faut dire que l'idée de la médiathèque
était une idée de la municipalité c'est
pas une idée de l'opposition et de la
baltique
donc c'est nous qui avons initié cette
médiathèque aujourd'hui effectivement il
ya quelques difficultés à terminer quand
il ya des difficultés à terminer autre
chose il y à aussi saoulé dans la
gestion communale que certains ne
connaissent pas j'aurai jour viendrait
là dessus il y a des priorités urgentes
il y avait urgence de plus goûtés et
puis il ya des choses du genre de
concept quand vous vous retrouvez
quelques fois on construit la
médiathèque de la vieille classe et
qualité de nos priorités urgentes mais
aujourd'hui effectivement nous avons
priorisé d'autres choses
donc c'est un moment on se déplace et
développement donc aujourd'hui nous
reprenons depuis la ligne 1 nous
reprenons les études nous avons compris
que vont l'utiliser avec la spl
martinique pour que voit de nouveau
dynamiser cette date alors on va changer
de sujet dans quelques secondes mais
nous venons mais avant que thierry tanoh
vous important commenté cette affaire de
la médiane et il dit que c'est un
concept qui dépasse et monsieur le maire
je m'excuse mais sur sa vous êtes
vraiment vraiment vraiment autant je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que vous
personne ne parle du coût de
fonctionnement de ces structures
parce que c'est bien de réaliser des
médiathèques de récupérer une maison une
comme stevie wonder du mieux qu'elle
accueille non non non l'accueil sportif
le sang sur le centre de strasbourg qui
avait déjà été donnée à la ctm et
monsieur quand villa a jugé bon de la
reprendre
cette maison mais comment nous allons
supporter au niveau de la mairie
sachant l'état des finances de la
commune pour moi là nous supporter le
coût fonctionnement de ces structures
parce que non seulement le le concept
est dépassé moi je propose c'est là
qu'est ce que je vais faire on serait
bien pour une rivière et que le texte
soit transformé je ne sais pas en quoi
en tout cas qu'elle soit gérée par
l'intercommunalité parce qu'on parle ici
de municipal mais il ya aussi c'est une
élection une communauté tout à fait et
personne ne parle du vol de cap nau dans
tout ça on en parlait des tensions avec
la convention et toi ça permet aux
communes de faire des économies
d'échelle et de pouvoir éviter des coûts
de fonctionnement je n'ai pas entendu
nos marques nous passons à autre chose
au nom de la gestion communale
certains parlent d'opacité de manque de
transparence sur la situation financière
on parle de dette de 3 millions qu'à la
situation financière de la commune
je vais commencer par d'abord les
conseils municipaux que vous êtes
monsieur goûtera quelle est la situation
de la commune parce qu'on parle de pas
citer c'est ce que vous dites aussi la
situation financière et non pas à
travers le budget puisque on peut tout
faire dire un budget surtout avec les
restes à réaliser qu'on leur oppose
d'année en année mais à travers tout à
l'heure le contre administratif choquant
des exemples très précis pour voir le
niveau d'investissement de la commune et
qu' on ne peut pas développer une
commune
quant aux contres administratif on a
moins de 30000 jeudi me 30007 27 mille
et quelques euros pour en matière
d'investissement ce n'est pas pensable
mais pour bien que les auditeurs qui
nous écoutent la question déjà été posée
au conseil municipal puisque je
participe au conseil municipal
régulièrement lors du vote du compte
administratif
je demande au maire sortant de me
répondre
le budget c'est pareil aucun des
conseillers n'a la parole nadwa la
parole
le débat se déroule entre les deux
oppositions et monsieur le maire et
monsieur le maire n'est pas en mesure et
je répète il est pas en mesure de nous
répondre sur son pop au budget et je
demande à ce que le directeur général
des services n'étaient reviennent pas
dans les débats
c'est leur compte administratif du maire
donc c'est à lui de nous répondre
et quand on pense des questions comment
ça se fait que centre sportif le centre
d'hébergement qui était prévu avec un
financement unique n'a pas de
financement voici le plan de financement
et comme c'était prévu en novembre 2010
fin des travaux
regardez c'est un c'est signé de
monsieur et qu'en ville fait des travaux
octobre 2011 durée des travaux neufs
mois mais il a changé le projet entre
temps c'est non non non il n'a pas su le
faire parce que j'ai l'encontre qui
vivait chez d'être en charge de la
direction des politiques publiques
et justement et c'est cette direction
qui s'occupe de l'aide aux communes
l'aide de la collectivité territoriale
aux communes il ya eu plusieurs et à ce
titre je le dis vraiment chaque fois
qu'il ya un dossier du carbet je fais en
sorte effectivement ce dossier soient
poussées il ya eu des demandes de
réaffectation de la sphère juridique
laudine par les autres
la place jury vide on sait que le jeu
vous bloquez les deux hommes on va
parler chaque fois qu'il fait des
demandes qui ne reçoit pas de réponse on
continue sur cet exemple la place jules
grévy dont on vient de parler il y avait
c'est une opération qui était déjà
financé depuis l'époque de monsieur
mouiller s il ya une demande de
réaffectation nous avons fait je
respecte à sion 1 2 réaffectation pousse
le centre sportif le sens sportif ce qui
va se passer nous aurons une difficulté
c'est que sans la 7e que le centre
national de développement du sport nous
demande aujourd'hui de finaliser
monsieur vous avez déjà beaucoup
d'inventions entre vos comptes japon
plus je conclus alesi vraiment à dire
à défaut de l'achèvement du projet dans
un délai de quatre ans à compter de la
date de déclaration du commencement de
l'exécution l'opération sera considérée
comme terminée
ce qui veut dire qu'on ne pourra mème
pas faire dans ce cas bon pour l'état il
falloir que nous la nouvelle équipe a
l'on aille chercher les heureusement
pour le terminer le sens sportif voilà
monsieur vossen a fait une gestion
calamiteuse de monsieur champions d'unys
vérification concrets sur la gestion
justement monsieur levitte vous avez
plusieurs fois porté plainte
oui et vous êtes on vous parlait
d'opacité les au manque de transparence
bien sûr monsieur oui alors la première
chose on va parler de la dette
elle est de 3 millions effectivement
d'accord si ou 3500 habitants nous avons
700 6 foyers imposables ce qui fait ça
revient 4000 euros par foyer faut savoir
que le monsieur qu'en ville investie que
6e au 50 e par habitant et les documents
qu'ils nous donnent montrent que les
oies 7 d'investissement
des mondes coeur et rien n'a été fait et
pourtant il a eu les dotations qu'il
fallait vous savez monsieur et qu'en
ville a l'habitude de faire parler les
chiffres
et il fait tellement parler les chiffres
en 2015
oui j'ai saisi le tribunal administratif
et j'ai démontré que le budget n'était
pas équilibrée
j'ai démontré que les chiffres n'étaient
pas bons et j'ai démontré que sur c'est
ce conseil municipal j'ai démontré au
tribunal que 1
les convocations nous et a donné deux
jours avant le conseil municipal pour
nous empêcher de participer d'accord et
le tribunal administratif a annulé le
vote du budget 2015 de la commune de
garder il ya eu monsieur niveau oui vous
avez raison il ya eu deux autres recours
auprès du tribunal
c'est concernant l'office municipal
d'action culturelle et sportif qui m
n'en est mort il est mort il est mort y
est je peux aller jusqu'au bout monsieur
niveau oui vous avez une office le film
municipal qui est gérée par une alger
omeyer qui recevait 295 millions de
subventions 142 mille euros maximum par
la commune vous savez ce qui a été fait
que les sous est ce que vous vous avez
déjà été à barcelone
monsieur li oui vous connaissez
barcelone excellence vous pose une
question ne ressort selon moi non plus
là d'un goûter
peut il balance voilà ce que ça a servi
cinq six sept huit voyages par an sur le
compte de cet office municipal et c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est le documente
les documents qu'ils voyagent qui
voyagent et à monsieur écoutez monsieur
qu'en ville est bien placé pour nous
dire qu'ils voyagent d'aujourd'hui si
vous assurez vous je ne donnerai aucun
nom il a un an je demanderai pas d
identité est ce que c'est quoi une
église à rabotnicki visite d'agrément
chaleur
un séminaire où le conseil
d'administration justement veut prendre
de cet office est composée au moins de
60% d'élus c'est bien clair donc c'est
l'équipe dirigeante de l'office qui
partait voyager en espagne isaf
il a fallu que le tribunal exige que
monsieur qu'en ville me donne les
documents pasteur il ne les donnerai pas
pour qu'ils puissent les données
aujourd'hui nous sommes à cette
situation très bien thierry claveau sur
donc l'aspect que sont abordés à l'aller
je suis très surpris agréablement
surpris de savoir que la commune du
carbet n'a que 3 millions d'endettement
c'est formidable parce que quand je vois
fort de fos a coûté 180 3 et 2 font sens
d'endettement je dis merci
bon c'est très raisonnable il soyons
soyons sérieux
et puis quand j'entends vous donner un
satisfecit s'est alors montré neil
maintenant peut-être qu'on confonde
l'internement et le déficit parce que
c'est souvent ce qui se passe même pour
les journalistes quand augmentant vos
commentaires on attend souvent pas les
noms des plats et réalités ce déficit le
déficit est pas le rythme est endetté et
de petr déficit et versements mais tout
ça me fait dire que voilà bon c'est pas
facile de gérer une commune vous avez
c'est pas donné à n'importe qui alors je
ne critique pas laisser ça peut enlever
il peut avoir des loupés ont tout le
monde allait louper j'entends ici et là
par les deux lomax de ceci de cela
excite et reste c'est ça le véritable
enjeu est ce que c'est ça le véritable
enjeu parce que le george v fut contre
qui je n'ai absolument rien il a quand
même été adjoint au maire de monsieur et
qu'en ville pendant des années et où il
était détenteur d'une délégation du
maire
en même temps ce pouvait être à fleury
mérogis alors je vous avais vu avant en
fait non pas par contre barcelone
barcelone ce travail et comment faisait
at il pu exercer ses fonctions de maire
à qui monsieur l'écho fils
d'ailleurs je vous appris que j'étais en
ville de rome d'avoir donné
envie d indemnités un adjoint qui
n'était pas sur place
et quand je l'entends s'acharner contre
lui max je comprends ce qu'il dit sauf
que bon jovi lui georges du feedback et
plus et qu'on en finisse données en
bresse porté plainte contre qui de droit
et que la justice puisse faire son
travail de façon définitive dans les
landes est candidat oui oui d'abord je
rejoue et oui il ya beaucoup donc saisi
le maire un dock sinon c'est normal que
conte macabre et je dois dire il ya même
eu des accusations oui absolument et
argumentée et a augmenté de deux points
de vue de l'autre oui alors dans mon jeu
je rejoins monsieur caveau monsieur
griffith ne connaît pas la différence
entre déficit et l'endettement
alors je sais pas où l'appui ces
chiffres de plus ce plateau autre que le
vôtre il méconnaît de la gestion
puisqu'il disait que la chambre des
comptes n'étaient revient pas au dessous
de d'une commune de toi mais c'est donc
on voit bien que monsieur mais fut de la
partie compétences ou de gestion au
final voilà déjà donc ce cas vous
remercie de nu la commune du car benny
comme une demoiselle d'été de la vente
est une des communes les moins visités
d'amande
donc ça c'est deux mondes ensuite
c'était pourtant cette affaire au max
j'ai parlé de lomax d'avant lomax
voulait découvert ce n'est pas une
nouveauté de jeu conséquent le mc saïda
mais nous n'avons pas beaucoup de temps
on va pas refaire tous les packs de
répondre et que vous vous laissiez comme
je dois faire je pose une question
comment je suis emballé par edward
parole vous allez parler aux mains sur
mon combat c'est une mauvaise qu'on
croit le maire va à barcelone pour des
gouttes voilà c'est ce que je voulais
alors traduire ce conduit que vous êtes
allé à barcelone mais poli mais non je
suis jamais sorti de la boîte il est
donc aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas un
domaine où je réponds monsieur sur
l'essoufflement des précieux gisements
et comme salué comme d'habitude alors
monsieur qui fut une autre de
stigmatiser des enseignants les
enseignants lomax avec cette affaire de
subventions c'est comme linux et erasmus
vous avez hélas ne sais quoi oui les
enseignants le cinéma ont été
effectivement avoir
merci dieu local europe et mais voilà
dans le cadre des grâces ils ont été à
l'université a été dans des hôtels et
monsieur aujourd'hui monsieur et wii fit
stigmatise aussi des signaux qui ont
travaillé pour le câble des signes qui
ont sorti les enfants du père abbé de la
zep de la zone d'éducation prioritaire
aujourd'hui sont fiers de ces
enseignants fier de la des enseignants
aujourd'hui monsieur jette l'opprobre
six étudiantes nancy le connais pas je
ne connais pas sa loyauté coup l europe
a besoin
si sa carrière au bout c'est pas la même
si très calme nous à l'examen des
auditeurs non j'espère qu'à mon scooter
weekend mais c'est top c'est là c'est
quand la monterie et à ce niveau il faut
une poutre si nous voyons que je ne
répondais pas je les chefs d'îlot des
choses une loterie ou mentionnait ben
oui oui mais c'est mon trip on
comprenait et là on connaît pas on
connaît pas encore de 10 euros 7 euros
trois milieux autant de matches au lieu
des chiffres qu'on peut pas ça c'est
grave pour être mère vous vous savez
être mais alors vous griser des shifter
20 on vous a donné un petit papier oui
vous savez pas vous savez faire parler
les chiffres monsieur griffith nuisibles
effectivement le trajet d'abord chariot
plus la procédure alors plus globalement
on vous êtes donc fiers de votre bilan
n'y a pas d'eau basés chez les déchets
mais bon voilà bien sûr mais tout à fait
mais je leur ai fait on quand on vous
dit que c'est la commune la moins
endettée devenant une des communes et
vous ai dit que je voulais vous dire
écoutez je vous le rite vous prenez un
verre et vous le remplissez aujourd'hui
ces missiles au nom de mes concurrents
de voir les cas le cac est vide
si le leader et vocaux de maths radio
edit je comprends mais il ya trois
quarts de ceux vers l'acquis son plein
trois quarts qui sont pleins et qui
effectivement vont vous allez je pense
que vous allez en parler vous parler des
problèmes valent aussi aussi les choses
qui vont bien
je voulais juste revenue sur le bourg le
bo où nous avons un projet aussi d'un
projet de 20 logements avec en dessous
de ces logements en rez-de-chaussée des
locaux d'activités pour des médecins ou
pour des commerces
vous voyez que nous sommes aussi de
cette dimension de données entre bourg
une activité une activité principale
activité de
culture je les dis aussi une activité de
de travail de l'activité de commerce ça
a été pourtant voilà ce que je voulais
et je quand je parle comme ça je parle
précisément alors effectivement il y a
la rétrospective mais il ya surtout
aussi la prospective comme à ton donné à
nos futurs aller nous poursuivons il
reste un tout petit peu plus d'un quart
d'heure démission et et de débats à
niveau oui nous allons parler du
développement économique et touristique
on parle beaucoup du marouba d'accroire
landes d'agritourisme de spirit tourisme
quelles sont vos propositions dans ce
domaine on revient monsieur griffith et
poté le carbet est une commune tournée
aussi bien vers la mer à la campagne
il faut qu'on favorise l'installation
des entreprises
il faut développer ce twizz ce
aujourd'hui le twist il passe il ne
s'arrête pas au carbet pourquoi parce
que rien n'a été fait pour qu'il puisse
s'arrêter sur la carte des plats quand
on voit les quand on voit les comment
dire les restaurants liseret subventions
vous sont pleines touristes mais les
restaurants sont fans tous les
restaurateurs se débrouille e ou faire
venir les touristes
aujourd'hui le touriste et traverse il
va sur saint pierre
monsieur et moi je vous dis il faut
développer ce tourisme et la possibilité
de développer sur twizz nous avons des
sites
il faut leur sens et les lois censées il
faut créer un parcours touristique
il faut qu'on travaille avec les marins
pêcheurs
il faut crier un twizz un tourisme un
tourisme
vers un quiz sportif de randonnée c'est
possible nous avons les pythons il faut
dynamiser la commune là on a beau dire
ce qu'on veut monsieur la commune n'est
pas dynamisé aujourd'hui il faut
travailler avec les marins pêcheurs
puisque monsieur qu'en ville pandore
bleus ce sont des éléments de langage
qui l'a jamais pu expliquer il faut
qu'on travaille excellement les pêcheurs
casse qui a été mise en place avec ses
marins pêcheurs voilà thierry claveau le
carbet était quasiment la seule commune
encore récemment à voir
à noter à peu près digne de ce nom bon
voilà maintenant il y en a plus et puis
on voit pas de perspectives de ce point
de vue là vous le candidat que vous êtes
comment vous envisagez ça est-ce que
vous avez des propositions à faire de ce
point de vue là écoutez moi je pense qu
on soit fond sauf énorme émoi dans ce
débat politique de déni news
considérable c'est une affaire qui a été
géré par la région de l'époque
à la demande de monsieur chimie qui
avait utilisé le préfet avec
l'établissement public foncier pourrait
en portage sur 7 de façon à ce que
c'était son choix politique de ne pas
commenter
il avait fait ce portage dans le but de
faire la région et la cites la city elle
devenue c'était un devenir propriétaire
de ce bien donc c'est pas une affaire
qui que le sous laquelle mère internée
où il peut être placé il peut impulser
peut avoir une vue si nous sommes
d'accord
nous sommes d'accord mais de même il
veut impulser l impression de mettre de
la pression qui peut les choisir je sais
nous sommes d'accord mais c'est la ctm
qui sera lé qui voit le dernier mot même
si je ne cherche pas je dis que le make
up et un rôle à jouer là-dedans mais
personne n'a dit ici que c'était la
faute du maire sortant mais bon sa
passion c'est en constatant que la
sienne parce que j'ai entendu des choses
pour des inepties je veux dire quand
même une chose importante c'est que le
développement économique depuis la loi
nôtre est de la compétence de la
communauté d'agglo l'autorisent est de
la compétence de la communauté d'agglo
ça n'empêche pas au meilleur prix sur
demande seulement ça concerne sommes
d'accord mais sous ce à quoi se faire en
accord avec parce que là je n'ai pas de
vision il n'y aura pas d'accord sur un
terrain à cause des incendies n'a pas de
vision il n'a pas de vision lui mais moi
j'en ai une
mais il faut qu'elles soient sérieuses
parce qu'il s'agit pas de sous prétexte
qu'on veut avoir une vision de dire
n'importe quoi il ya une compétence qui
est transférée c'est celle du tourisme
là l'état là où le séjour et gênait pas
mais thierry cave ou en même temps alors
ça veut dire que le meilleur finalement
doit cesser leurs ébats
gilbert sont démunis par les interros
donc non non mais c'est non ça c'est
votre
ceci dit je dis passagers mais on ne
peut pas avoir un rôle
et puis le maire ve est le meilleur au
jeu indique le maire de faire cesser la
municipalité afin de la ville en fin de
semestre les polices et oui il ya eu des
municipales mené par en mer dirigé par
le maire monsieur monsieur boutrin alors
sur le développement économique et
touristique de
du carbet vous avez quelque chose à
proposer
nous avons un véritable projet de
développement pour le carbet ce projet
de développement passe par une gestion
rationnelle intelligente les deniers
publics et surtout de l'occupation
spatiale de la commune nous allons
réviser le plan d'occupation des sols de
manière à permettre l'accueil d'une zone
d'activités artisanales économique de
manière à pouvoir terminer les chantiers
qui n'ont pas été terminés
nous allons également donné l'accent sur
deux quartiers important développement
des énergies renouvelables 2 vers son
capot on n'a pas parlé debout bras la
route d'abobo a été coupée pendant 12
ans monsieur le maire qui est également
maire sortant qui a été conseiller
général je rappelle qu'au fait que vous
êtes en avance 1 quand même sur tout le
monde
donc allez-y mais si vous pouviez
ramasser ça serait bien finalement un
1er mai place monsieur je souhaiterais
que l'on puisse crier une zone
d'activités une zone agricole protégée
il y en a qu'une seule actuellement 6 l
de rivière salée de manière à rendre
difficile et tout changement
d'affectation du foncier agricole jeu
notamment pour lutter a aussi du carbet
je souhaiterais qu'on puisse créer une
banque de terres communales financé à
70% par l'acquisition pour l'acquisition
des parcelles par lot d eux on ne
l'utilisent pas je souhaiterais
également que l'on puisse signer un bail
rural environnementale là encore c'est
possible depuis 2007 par le code rural
nous ne le faisons pas enfin de manière
très concrète il ya développement du
café arabica typique à café d'excellence
avis riez à bellefontaine au morne vert
à bernadette est également sur la
commune de fond saint denis au carbet tu
auras l'unité de transformation et de
torréfaction pour ce café d'excellence
que nous allons recevoir monsieur le
maire sur le payer et yellow
dix chances d'être je dirais correct je
n'ai pas fini mon propos je termine ma
phrase s'il vous plaît si je vous en
prie a lésé merci je dis c'est que cette
unité de transformation et de
torréfaction du café
on souhaiterait la domicilié non mr la
zone d'activités artisanales économique
que nous allons sur la bienveillance et
de swiss re est d'atteindre les propos
de monsieur boutruche bon c'est la
septième équipe on sait très bien au
contraire c'est formidable attaque à
tout va des fous de souvenez vous de sa
progéniture
souvenez vous de son projet google ici
et le cacao au carbet parce que quoi
bien habiter aux qualités opposante et
que monsieur marie jeanne la maison de
repos ça c'est aussi quelque chose vous
savez vous journalistes à tous les cas
jouer des reprises le propos de monsieur
mais chut
tu parles de dynamiser le quartier moi
je parle de m corbin dynamique et puis
c'est presque la même chose non non
c'est pas la sépaq dynamise et puis je
voulais dire puisqu'il parle à parler de
la zone bleue oui oui tout à fait nous
avons fait des fleurs blanches dans le
cerveau qui est envisagé c'est
absolument faux disais france il aux
bleus puisque nous avons pris une zone
marine une zone marine qui en accord
avec les pêcheurs et les plaisanciers
sirop dans les communes maritimes de
voix dit piché des pistes aussi
travailler ensemble et là nous avons
créé ces documents une saine d'une
haleine protégé qui permet aujourd'hui
de sauver la scène
vous savez cette scène là c'est celle où
quoi laisser pantois 10 kilos non
compatibles ou encore changer quand on
achète plus haut ça c'est là le social
ça c'est la culture
ça c'est le patrimoine de la martinique
et ça nous le savons nous avons six
queen's en éducative pour les enfants ça
aussi si le futur une zone éducative
marine
ça veut dire que les enfants sont près
de la plage et qu'il s'occupe du
développement durable s'occupe de la
place occupe il s'occupe de la deûle est
de la mer ça c'est magnifique et donc
aussi nous avons crié avec les
partenaires et ils verront débarquer
tout seul d'ailleurs je suis cobain
parle des licences ou d'ailleurs les
seconds on travaille avec nous en
partenariat avec les restaurants
dès l'es2 d'économie vous voulez pas que
je veuille ou non vous avez vous allez
venir mais on aura bien des gens ce que
c'est qu'un jour vous m'avez déjà tous
deux dit je suis sûr que vous allez
venez nous avons nous allons créer la
biche ils placent de biche
vous savez que le carbet c'est une des
communes où il ya là le plus le plus de
sport de deux plages est maintenant de
créer une zone de but ce fonds et s'est
fondu dans nous sommes nous sommes déjà
alors est-ce qu'un sport de plage oui à
célébrer tout à fait non c'est bon là au
coin à un prêt des restaurants du coin
il assez fort comme si celles à venir
alors vous voyez je vous pendant que les
jours je vois toujours prospectives nous
sommes pas dans dans la tente ou de
laisser faire ou bien il bon ça ne va
pas nous sommes très actifs et c'est ça
avec moi et ça c'est drôle mais vous
avez parlé monsieur carouge d'un v10 est
ce que ne doit pas avoir de vision oui
mr une vision et j'ai une vision quoi il
y en a une maison forte et malicieux
dynamique pour sa prise demain on vise
pour le tourisme ou la tourism
l'économique
on ne peut pas le bal nous avons vu de
l'activité qui est prévue au carbet nous
avons discuté où ils vous avez entendu
nous avons dû fuir les touristes non ce
qui est prévu au camp mais je peux vous
en avez sûrement dû à la rue avec avec
jay notablement vous poser nue sexe
était là oui alesi est ce que vous
considérez que l'aménagement paysager du
littoral de la plage oui et suffisamment
aboutie et du fise à m'en faire donc je
mens d'oran mais est ce que le même
nombre cette année il ya des priorités
ou gens nous avons un projet de 5
millions d'euros donc sur les affaires
mais bien sûr tu as rouge nous avons
approché là-dessus et c'est ça nous ne
pouvons pas tout faire en même temps
vous avez vu rouler le tout je reviens
un peu sur ce que vous m'avez dit nous
ne pouvons pas toujours le temps mais
aujourd'hui le carbet et de cette
dynamique les élus du carbet sous de
cette position et là nous allons au fur
et à mesure que déroulé le projet tant
que nous pourrons tant que la situation
financière nous le permettra
ça c'est de vendre quelques mots avant
donc les conclusions je voulais juste
abordés mais alors vraiment je vais vous
demander d'être assez court ce que
chacun comment vous considérez cette
convention territoriale nord caraïbe
on rappelle qu' monsieur claveau vous
voyez pas de quoi je veux parler je
voulais suis d'accord nord caraïbe qui
compte 23 mille habitants donc c'est une
convention territoriale avec la
communauté d'agglomération cap nord et
la ctn 32 millions d'investissements
prévus dont 16 pour la part de la ctm il
ya déjà eu quelques réunions il ya donc
un comité de pilotage et la première
réunion moi même j'y assistais a eu lieu
à case-pilote est-ce que vous adhérez
jean claude et quand villa cette
convention territoriale nord caraïbe
avec 4 nord et là c'était tout à fait
tout ça qui vous inscrivez dans mes
voyages ca s'était élevé ne vois
pourquoi vous ne dites jamais passé les
caisses de cession qu'est ce que c'est
que ceux ci qu'est ce que c'est que ça
je travaille à castiel du travail pas
que les jeunes qui bloque j'applique dos
et ça c'est beau temps d'examen oui vous
savez je ne mange pas je t'aime ich habe
einen je m'excuse je le savais je
voudrais juste de revenir sur on an'a
blement le baril vous savez pourquoi le
baobab est pas fait parce que monsieur
boutry ses amis bloque lorsque j'ai
touché 4000 euros par mois c'était bon
et ça fait je suis à 1000 euros
je ne touche pas et c'est ça monsieur le
salage invités vous comprenez est patent
au delà de la 3d par satellite et voilà
la vérité monsieur carouge je suis
admiratif après la volée de bois vert
comme je suis qu'en ville a reçu en
télévision lors du dernier débat
il ose venir dire aujourd'hui sous le
plateau que c'est la cité m on vient de
lui expliquer à l'instant que ce portage
foncier faire par un établissement
public foncier local le pfl martinique
et que ce n'est pas là cités m
mais t'es tu vas comprendre la voile un
territoire provençal
j'aurais voulu dire craintes
monsieur et qu'en ville dans sa
profession de froid promet qu'il y aura
un transport interurbain et qui ne l'a
pas fait pendant qu'il était conseil
général
il n'a pas fait le transport urbain oui
le transport est fait mais ce n'est pas
ce que je veux dire ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on souhaiterait que le maire
sera présent lors des réunions comme les
autres maires de la haute parce que nous
avons besoin de partenaires pour mettre
des abris bus
mais qui sait le modèle des prix des
taxis des moyens de vue technique c'est
dans votre famille vous mettiez voit le
jour de pâques rhin ils vous diront
merci a compris ce qu'on vit en conseil
municipal
c'est à dire on ne vous laisse pas
parler mais vous permettez que je
m'exprime là dessus la vérité aux
français
certes nous souhaitons qu'il y ait des
arrêts de bus avec des horaires mais si
on ne peut pas le faire seul on peut le
faire avait très bien partenaires qui le
même genre griffith la convention
territoriale de développement via ce cap
nord et c'était bien sûr nous est pour
vous vous inscrivez à sion ce monsieur
nous adhérons en terrassement cette
convention et puisque nous n'aurons pas
le choix de travailler avec aussi bien
cap nau que la cdm
c'est sa sincérité nous ne serons pas
nous ne serons pas comme la municipalité
actuelle qui refusent de travailler
justement avec la ctm vous l'avez dit
oui nous travaillons vraiment moi je
vais pas dire poser une question oui
messieurs car oui si ça peut lui arriver
je travaille il m'a dit aussi bien avec
la ctm et avec quel que soit le
président de la ctm qui sera là et aussi
bien à carnon et son président alors
tiré claveau pied sur route et rien ne
peut pas ne pas souscrire à une telle
initiative puisque on appelle nouveux ce
fameux schéma de mutualisation des
moyens des services qui doit être fait
avec un nom et je suis d'autant plus
surpris quand même d'autant que la cité
est bon que monsieur bout très bloc
moi je crois que c'est un faux débat
également je me permets de vous le dire
parce que je ne vois pas bon comment
monsieur boutrin petit bloqués si dd
état de dépenses monsieur le maire sont
remontées des états d'exit des rapports
d'exécution intermédiaire des
différentes opérations
ce sont des pratiques mans ce sont des
dotations les l'écho la contribution de
la ctm aux communes
c'est pratiquement une dotation il ya
des conventions donc je n'imagine pas
avant mousse comme ce bouquin des
pouvoirs extraordinaires qui puisse
arriver honnêtement honnêtement à
bloquer dès que vous faites remonter vos
factures avec vos étapes dépend certifié
par votre comptable la 7e doit
s'exécuter puisqu'elle à la convention
elle est connue par la convention de
financement de l'opération d'accord donc
moi je pense que c'est un faux débat
mais je suis très heureux de sa non pas
sur cette cette convention avec oui il
ya d'administration et non à la
politique très bien la corde et convient
aux sportifs et politiques voient la
tension mais voilà tu peux maintenant
mais l'om sera-t-il confond soyons
soyaux financement nous avons affaire à
des politiques mais il sait tout la
concession de finances invention pipart
doit nous allons nous aller dit non au
terme de cette élection de façon que tu
te conclusion une minute par candidat
nous avons de commencer par monsieur le
maire sortant qui attend les camps ville
donc votre conclusion
en une minute oui je voudrais d'ailleurs
je remercie d'abord ce débat qui m'a
permis de mieux l'ex fini que de
quelques temps avant c'est important que
je vais pas on a dit à des manoeuvres
dilatoires et donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ils peuvent la population
haïtienne consciente elle est consciente
du choix elle est consciente que l'on
doit servir le plus large aux plus
étroit elle est consciente que entre une
famille un ego entre tous ces gens-là
entraîneurs ont choisi le lac août
l'équipe qui est la plus responsable
si en devenir d'ailleurs notre slogan
ensemble en confiance
nous devons continuer voyez les soirs
des termes forts ensemble ensemble avec
la population en confiance parce que la
conf la population nous fait confiance
et continuent à nous faire confiance
d'ailleurs tout le reste des seconds et
en tout cas continuer donc nous allons
continuer à développer notre corps des
salons continuer à vendre une commune
attractive dans le contenu avant une
commune de la dimension et ses oncles
des cons ville
merci nous écoutera chef hervé siens
c'est le moment de décider ensemble
d'une nouvelle exigence pour notre
commune en cette période on le dit de
déclin démographique de crise économique
durable et des certitudes sur les
finances publiques le carbet aveu besoin
d'une équipe solidaire une équipe
d'hommes et de femmes compétentes
expérimenté avec effectivement la loi du
7 décembre du 7 août 2015 pour la
répartition des compétences
avec cap nord et la cité m c'est une
nouvelle culture à la froide ministre
at-il politique et fiscale qui va
falloir adopter pour sortir de cette
gestion inefficiente lymphatique et
faire face aux défis de demain nous à
l'annonce caby ciel nous sommes prêts
nous plan de financement sont déjà
bouclées il ne manque que vous rejoignez
nous dès le premier tour je dis bien dès
le premier tour voter pour la liste de
l'alliance gavi ciel et nous vous
donnons rendez vous le 7 février à 18h30
à la paillote merci nous pourrons voir
merci voir notre prochaine et la vie ce
qui portera ce projet votre conclusion
maintenant c'est à vous thierry lavât
vous pouvez écouter ma conclusion est
très simple je demande le chaos haïtien
de pointe conscience qu'en douze ans il
ya eu très peu de choses de réaliser je
vais pas dire qu'il n'a pas eue il ya
quelque chose de réaliser aujourd'hui il
faut adopter une méthode je ne vais pas
vendre du rêve aux galiciens
je ne vais pas du houga bi sien
aujourd'hui voilà ce que je vais faire
que je vais faire ceci ou cela je veux
d'abord savoir quelle est la situation
exacte
cette commune pouvoir quels sont ses
capacités et je veux rester dans les
compétences de la commune et de
l'intercommunalité
je ne veux pas prendre les compétences
ni du parc naturel ni du de la ctm ou
partie ou dans des dans des délires
impossible et puis après décevoir comme
beaucoup comme beaucoup au niveau
national on fait beaucoup de promesses
et n'ont pas réussi à les satisfaire
et puis donc pour conclure louis-georges
griffi alors allez-y conclut je veux
dire tout simplement premièrement nous
avons à travers ce débat vu le
positionnement de monsieur claveau et la
mission qui lui a été confié je veux
dire à monsieur klaus que quand on aime
le carbet on commence par s'inscrire sur
la liste électorale
deuxièmement je veux dire aux cars
baissier 12 ans d'immobilisme 12 ans où
nous sommes restés là immobile nous tel
un élève qui passent le bac qui n'a rien
fait pendant l'année scolaire et qui
demande à son prof une nouvelle chance
aujourd'hui car b nou paka puisqu'on est
une commune de marée pêcheurs ne pas pas
fonctionné puis pagaille épigrammes
encore c'est nous avons des moteurs un
gps et on fixe le cap violé des cpie
nous demandons au maire sortant de
laisser la possibilité aux quarts des
siens qui veulent travailler de fixer un
cap pour l'avenir du carbet merci à vous
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat qui
a été d'une bonne tenue un débat réalisé
par rodrigue calix rendez vous pour le
prochain débat lundi donc à 18h15 on
vous ménage le suspense pour savoir de
quelle commune
il s'agira mais on vous demande d'être
présent bonne soirée car si ces
élections municipales le débat
[Musique]
non
a'salfo nettoyer
et
[Musique]
symphonia
et
[Musique]
car
j'aime pas
j'ai pas vu
tha
[Musique]
oh
là